[Music]
the Oscars are this coming Sunday and
everyone's got Oscar fever none of us do
but anyway the Oscars are coming up this
Sunday and there are nine nominees for
Best Picture here's the problem a lot of
people haven't seen all the movies right
so don't you worry Andy and I are here
to help okay
each night we're gonna perform a pivotal
scene from one of the nominated films
that way this weekend when you're
watching the Oscars with your friends
you'll know what you're talking about
you'll have a leg up because you saw us
perform some of these scenes now to
begin tonight we've chosen the artists
okay it's a silent movie
shot in black and white yeah and the
scene that we're doing is the first time
you see silent film star George Valentin
yeah that's right he's he's just
premiered his latest movie the audience
is going wild yeah and he loves all the
adulation he ends up doing a tap dance
routine as he hungers for more applause
exactly and I'll be paying playing him
I'll be playing his
your mustache delivery sorry that's okay
I'd I'll be playing his disapproving
co-star Constance who stands in the
wings not amused by her partner's antics
right you do not approve of what I'm
doing I don't approve it all but I
approve with this dress okay we now
present you a scene from the artist and
begin
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]